[Musique]
le fait que nous soyons services de
santé fait qu'il y à une complexité dans
l'organisation actuelle de cette
vaccination puisque cette vaccination
est fait pour des personnes vulnérables
et nous ne pouvons pas agir comme nous
le faisions d'habitude en allant sur les
entreprises donc c'est pas une
vaccination dans l'entreprise c'est une
vaccination dans nos centres de santé au
travail au service des salariés des
entreprises que nous suivons s'est passé
ça la vraie définition c'est une
facilité que l'on offre et on est
heureux de pouvoir participer à cette
campagne nationale et à favoriser la
vaccination parce que pour nous
favoriser les vaccinations pour des
personnes vulnérables
c'est quelque chose qui est extrêmement
positif voilà plutôt comment nous
appréhendons cette vaccination est ce
que c'est une plus value de vacciner sur
travaille actuellement
compte tenu d'une part d'un manque de
racler important en vente une
connectique que saab d'ailleurs et
l'importance il faut acheter plus de
monde la population bon c'est pas
l'entreprise n'est pas invincible en soi
en tout cas il est sous capot pulation
par quels travailleurs qu'ils soient en
soit 50 cent quatorze en coloriser est
un accès à ce cette troisième phase de
vaccination
c'est important maintenant la plupart de
ces gens qui sont commandités ou un
médecin traitant déjà donc ils peuvent
elles sont chinoises après tant que le
sont au travail puisse s'organiser pour
en faire ce que la wii mais il va parce
qu'on va se mettre à la place le système
de soins qui fait très bien cela qui est
préventif que la vaccination pour les
services de santé c'est pas d'ma
pourquoi c'est pas demain parce que nous
ne pouvons pas utiliser les entreprises
pour contacter les salariés ne pouvons
pas envoyer des convocations aux
salariés par l'intermédiaire des drh
nous ne pouvons pas contacté les
salariés restent messagerie
professionnelle nous ne pouvons que
faire passer les messages
et vous nous y aider en tant que média
vous passer l'information comme quoi les
salariés peuvent nous
appelez on va pas plus être
interventionniste que ça au niveau des
sociétés et pas avoir plus de regards
c'est à dire qu'on va même pas donnée à
l'employeur en retour sur les
vaccinations qu'on l'a fait
non ça va être totalement neutre notre
notre action éventuellement des salariés
peuvent demander à nous rencontrer comme
cela est permis par la législation du
travail en demandant une visite à la
demande du salarié à son employeur mais
ça n'ira pas au delà
justement dans cette préoccupation de
secret médical qui est absolument
incontournable suis inquiète beaucoup
plus courts l'accessibilité à la
salariée direct ou seul santé au travail
un peu ça qui est déficiente depuis
plusieurs années l'application de
l'heureuse de le relancer et le fait la
terminale en surprises et parfois 9,5
important mais s'ils travaillent peuvent
venir vers nous je suis un peu d'accord
avec tous des précautions qu'annoncé
mais mme chartier et ce sujet c'est la
proposition actuellement est pas
construite elle même pas évolué sur le
rendement ça aura donc je crois que
c'est c'est une ce que c'est un
affichage que nous ne sommes jamais on
va prendre 20 de moyens mais vous
comprenez que quand les arrivants pointe
du rendez-vous sera content assure après
la logique de ces rendez vous avec les
disponibilités de travail qu'on a et des
vaccins qu'on a il ça sera ça sera pas
évident donc ce matin un dialogue qui va
être compliqué avec les salariés
directement la question aujourd'hui sur
la campagne vaccination c'est pas les
vaccinateurs et vaccinateurs y en a on
peut on être aussi pour acheter
la question c'est les vaccins on va bien
moi j'en fais qu on stage c'est par le
jeu j'ai parlé multiplier et éviter de
deux de détourner cette distribution
vaccins en avoir plus d'enfants rôle
dans un autre il faut que toute la
population est accès de façon équitable
voilà ce qu'on peut dire on va suivre
cette production à cette progression
précise ce père de deux filles et des
vaccins
on verra ce qu'on peut faire avec mais
pour l'instant c'est la faible et
sionistes et des vaccins antoine réseau
opérationnel
cette mesure comment ça se fait que le
froid par l opérationnel nation et de la
disponibilité
j'ai une vision extrêmement pragmatique
des choses c'est à dire que je suis
allée avec ma carte cps chez le
pharmacien pour lui demander de me
commander puisque la première commande
c'est une ampoule de 10 doses dont j'ai
été commandé ma première en pole de 10
doses et je vais voir
après j'ai eu quelques entreprises de
moyenne importance un peu plus tôt des
pâtes ou des toutes petites mais des
moyens qui ont déjà fait la démarche de
savoir comment ça se passait donc je
vais les informer que nous avons enfin
je les ai informés que nous avions des
vaccins à disposition et que c'est vous
pouvez faire passer une information aux
salariés
donc maintenant j'attends le retour pour
arriver à avoir dans une matinée une
dizaine de salariés puisque leur poule
fait dix doses